kyle is with us in atlanta hey Kyle how
are you well it's an honor to speak to
the great maja Ramsey well you may be
underwhelmed brother what's up well I
guess my question for you is uh kind of
a moral question well it's kind of I
guess that that type of question I have
an opportunity to lead your class at my
church
however I've got I'm dealing with I
struggle with a with an addiction it's
not gambling but I just want to know if
I'm if I'm fit to lead the class at my
church well will that interfere with you
loving people well as you lead the class
I'm sorry you said well your addiction
interfere with you loving people well
that are in the class or cause you to
give them bad financial advice it would
not okay then then I wouldn't have an
objection to it you know it's probably a
good idea to walk it through with your
pastor and if your pastor is cool with
it knowing what's going on then that
that's whose leadership you're under in
this scenario in terms or does he want
someone in the church leading and I
don't know what the ins and outs are how
long have you been dry are you dry
yes how long you been clean yeah well I
mean I I'm it's it's it's a I don't know
if you how much detail you are it's not
it's not a have you not been engaged in
the activity uh for about a few months
now I suppose okay are you in some kind
of an a a group or support group of some
kind in the process well I've been
meeting with a fellow friend of mine in
the church you know on a somewhat
regular basis and then I've just started
this this I guess
it's a it's a it's a it's a series or
not series but a kind of a book and a
support group called the pilgrimage to
it I don't know if you've heard of it no
I haven't but that's fine okay the point
is aren't you're dealing with this and
you're making progress is that what
you're telling me yes good good for you
congratulations I'll tell you man you
come you overcome stuff like that you
can do anything and I don't have in you
know we have forty thousand churches
that have taught financial peace classes
which means we've had a more
coordinators than forty thousand to my
knowledge I don't to my I could be wrong
but I don't think any of them are
perfect I think most of most of them are
probably human beings that have got
something screwed up including the guy
on the video me so we're not looking for
perfect folks we're looking for folks
that are trying and at their life and I
just you know if you think you're gonna
do something that's damaging to someone
in the class in any way then you would
call yourself out on that no to this
addiction but if if it's just hey I fell
down I've goofed up and I'm on my way
out of that and I'm do it taking the
steps to come on my way out of that
that's who I love is people who are
fighting their way through this thing
called our human race journey right yes
sir
but but again I you know that's just you
and me talking on the radio if I were in
your shoes I would just sit down with
your pastor and say this is what's going
on and I want to make sure you're okay I
got I seem to have this thing on the run
I'm doing this class I'm got some
accountability I'm here's my steps I've
not engaged in activity for this many
months and so I've been dry that's what
we call it in that world for that many
months and so pastor I just wanted you
to be aware of that and make sure that
you were okay with me leading this class
I don't think it's gonna cause any kind
of problem but I didn't want you to be
surprised and I'm you know this is your
church and I want to make sure
everything's okay and you know and and
you know whoever's in charge their
pastor whoever will look at you and say
takes class probably right okay yeah
yeah I imagine so and I've been praying
about it as well so it
so but you know I was just interested to
get your your opinion or your take on it
yeah I mean that the whole thing is
based on a guy who was a total screwup
me you know right yeah that's how this
all started I lost everything because I
was stupid I've done stupid with zeros
on the end I know what it looks like I
got a PhD in D um B so dude I'm all
about grace cuz I am in desperate need
of it the trick is just don't put
yourself in a position in a leadership
role where you're gonna bring harm to
someone you're supposed to be serving
and if you're not then I'm not gonna
worry about you man I'm an easy guy this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]